[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
einen schönen guten abend hierbei die
richtigen fragen spezial zur wahl in den
vereinigten staaten von amerika in
ungefähr 48 stunden werden die
amerikaner an die wahl angehen und
entscheiden wer wird oder wer bleibt der
nächste präsident der vereinigten
staaten und es geht um einen start um
einen staat in diesem land nämlich um
den staat pennsylvania und genau dort
begrüßen wir heute abend unseren gras
trick wenn er den ehemaligen botschafter
der vereinigten staaten hier in berlin
aber auch einen der engsten vertrauten
ein mann der in den letzten jahren
donald trump begleitet hat der mit ihm
zeit im oval office in der hochphase von
corona verbracht hat der für ihn
internationale vereinbarungen verhandelt
hat und der donald verbessere kennt als
die allermeisten menschen im umfeld von
donald trump in pittsburgh pennsylvania
jetzt live zugeschaltet ist anscheinend
zu dir nach bensberg julia und danke
dass ich hier bei euch ist sein darf
pittsburgh in pennsylvania ich würde
wirklich ganz knapp in pinsel werden ja
in der gestern gesagt deutschland will
mich draußen haben warum denkt er dass
das deutschland das die deutschen ihn
nicht haben wollen als präsident
man kann die zeitungen
wir lesen auch die schlagzeilen meter
das höre ich jeden tag von unseren
deutschen kontakten und seit einigen
jahren haben wir das immer wieder gehört
ich höre das von freunden und bekannten
beständig auch ganzen namen normale
deutschen außerhalb berlins
sie hoffen dass donald trump gewinnen
möge aber die eliten die männer an der
macht
meinung diejenigen die eben auch das
sagen in der hauptstadt haben all diese
menschen scheinen glücklich was gegen
kamp zu haben es geht hier aber nicht so
sehr um einen gegensatz zwischen
demokraten und republikanern nein es
geht um einen gegensatz zwischen denen
die mittendrin sitzen die an den hebeln
der macht sitzen und denen die draußen
sind donald trump ist keiner von innen
drin
von dieser macht elite er ist ein
geschäftsmann joe biden dagegen ist seit
47 jahren mitten in dieser macht elite
wir wissen eben von joe biden seine
gesamte vergangenheit hier insbesondere
in pennsylvania wissen die leute schon
mit wem sie es zu tun haben
am dienstag werden sie zur wahl gehen
und wir sind feste überzeugung trend
präsident deutschland der welt er hat
auch china und iran
dass der ganze andere kategorie sollte
da deutschland damit dazu gehören
für deutschland ist das sind
gefährliches oder ein feindliches an für
ihn
nein wir sind natürlich weiterhin
verbündete für deutschland das ist
natürlich die große enttäuschung für
amerikaner dass die europäer einfach
sich so und so verhalten
die deutschen auf der straße die sind
doch dieser meinung dass deutschland
auch den angemessenen beitrag für die
nato leisten müsste finanziell die
größte volkswirtschaft in europa sollte
doch auch den angemessenen beitrag
leisten das ist aber nicht der fall
das ist wirklich eine enttäuschung und
auch eine gewisse verbitterung dieses
argument habe ich wohl tausend mal schon
angeführt als ich mich in berlin bewegt
aber der gedanke dass die größte
wirtschaft europas einfach nicht genug
zahlt was sie zahlen müsste das ist
tatsächlich eine art
enttäuschung insbesondere interessant
russlands ja es ist eben eine quelle von
enttäuschungen für viele amerikaner
sie haben da das gefühl dass deutschland
nicht an unserer seite steht
ich glaube hat sich sehr eingesetzt für
die transatlantische partnerschaft
er wollte wirklich dass diese
partnerschaft wirklich robust
unterfütterte es ist ja kein geheimnis
deutschland und andere haben begonnen
sich von diesen westlichen werten zu
entfernen
wir wollen natürlich europa und
deutschland als eine starke verlässliche
partnerschaft es sollte nicht alles
immer sehr lange dauern etwa wenn man
das wirklich können wir viel zeit haben
sie mit viel zeit mit dem präsidenten
verbracht über 100 tage waren sie bei
ihm im oval office während der korona
krise in welcher stimmung ist eher dass
es eine hoch umkämpfte wahl 48 stunden
sind es noch bis zur wahl
es ist ein fenster gibson ein ticken wie
er denkt und wie es ihm geht
er ist immer noch zuversichtlich er ist
optimist und er sieht dass seine
unterstützer war es ist wirklich an
seinen fersen ist und dass er sich auf
sie verlassen kann
insbesondere in diesen schaukel staaten
im mittleren westen auf dieser
westlichen route hat carolina auch also
in diesen unsicheren start wie es ist
wirklich und und und
wirklich ermutigend zu sehen die energie
die im entgegen strömen er schaut sich
an er sieht wirklich einen gewaltigen
unterstützerkreis julian so etwas habe
ich in meinem ganzen leben nicht gesehen
reagan hat er natürlich auch die massen
auf seiner seite donald trump hat
wirklich eine ganz unglaubliche menge
zusammen geschafft
man sieht hier die arbeiterklasse
amerikas man sieht die hispanics die
geiser das ist wirklich groß der
versammlung die ich in dem gesamten
wahlkampf gesehen eine massive koalition
hat trump zusammengebracht
ich glaube wirklich dass diese menschen
vom sieg überzeugt sagt du hast
erfahrung damit
mit den versionen die trump hat zum
beispiel mit kanzlerin merkel wasser
enge kenntnisse gibt uns eine kurze
übersicht welche beziehung hatten die
die war nicht stressfrei
was erwarten wir von seinen denken über
die deutsche kanzlerin ich glaube er
respektiert sie zutiefst natürlich sie
hatten auch schwierige gespräche über
unterschiedliche politische auffassungen
aber sie hat in offene gespräche wie sie
zwischen verbündeten üblich sind
präsident hat gesagt ich schiebe ihnen
nicht die schuld zu
was da an nickligkeiten geschieht wenn
sie das nicht aufwenden können aber dann
sollten sie unsererseits uns auch nicht
als feind mit seinen oder ein nein wir
müssen einander als verbündete und
partner betrachten und auch behandeln
wir haben eine gemeinsame aufgabe vor
uns
in der nato und in vielen anderen fragen
zu dieser frage
die du uns gestellt hast die
transatlantische allianz liegt uns sehr
am herzen
trotz aller probleme die wir sind wir
wollen hier wirklich dem wir zusammen
führen es geht auch daran dass jeder
seine last trägt dir zu tragen hat die
menschen brauchen das gefühl dass die
nato den einsatz lohnt wir brauchen hier
das gefühl oder wir haben das gefühl
dass deutschland hinter seinen
verpflichtungen und zurück bleibt darum
geht es darüber sind die leute wirklich
teilweise erbittert einmal ein bisschen
darüber was passiert hinter den usa
jetzt im wahlkampf da es faszinierend
die ganze welt schaut es gibt viel auf
dem spiel stehen das die ganze welt
schaut präsident werden
und das läuft alles darauf hinaus dass
pennsylvania macht jeder deutschen
zuschauern warum spielt dass die große
rolle pennsylvania was da passiert
mittlere westen der diese entscheidende
schaltstelle ist wir haben hier dieses
wahlmänner system in den usa um nicht
kann sich damit ein essen wir haben aber
schutzmechanismen eingebaut für die
einzelnen staaten für die einzelnen
bezirke
dieses wahlsystem bedeutet dass man eine
repräsentative einteilung der gesamten
wählerschaft vorn hatte und man braucht
also 272 wahl und männerstimmen und
diese entscheidenden stimmen fährt man
eben
in bestimmten stadtteilen es ist ein
prozess wohl man sich die umfragen genau
anschauen muss wo man auch die
politischen planungen in einer reihe von
staaten ganz genau vorab bedenkt um eben
diese magische zahl von 272 wahlmännern
zu erreichen
und hier kommt es auch darauf an das
geld richtig einzusetzen um eben
wirklich gang die entscheide wahl
zusammen zu bekommen
viele sehen das mit unbedarften augen an
und wissen wir dass wenn wir uns nur auf
die großen konzentrieren wollten dann
würden wir den mittleren westen der so
wahlentscheidend ist vernachlässige
und man muss sich wirklich an die regeln
halten
man muss alle aspekte des amerikanischen
lebens angesehen nicht nur die
großstädte
viele medien viele umfragen sagen
breiten hat an vorsprung warum bist du
optimistisch dass es einen weg gibt zu
einem gewinn von jump hillary clinton
sie hat ja auch geglaubt dass sie
gewinnen ich würde 2016 alle waren
überzeugt sie würde gewinnen und sie hat
es nicht geschafft
tatsache ist dass die wahlen gehen immer
anders wir haben ja manchmal auch diesen
vorsichtigen konservativen der sich
nicht auf vortrag auch wegen der komik
könne müsse auch wegen der begrenzten
reichweite wir auf internationalen
medien habe
aber ich sehe präsident trampe kümmert
sich wirklich um die leute vor sich
wir haben einfach nicht die fähigkeit
dieser stadt für stadt
ort für ort abzulesen
einige berichterstatter gehört aber wir
hören dass kommentare von menschen die
von außerhalb der usa kommen
und die sind aber nicht wirklich dran an
dem was im lande vor sich geht
das heißt doch immer was sie gesehen
haben dort vor ort warum ist der große
unterschied bei den umfragen
was kann falsch ein an den umfragen also
die umfragen sind wirklich sehr
aufschlussreichen ich habe nie an die
umfragen geglaubt man nimmt irgendwie
600 personen und hält das wir
repräsentieren die meisten umfragen
richten sich auch nach der vorgeschichte
der jeweiligen welle dass man sagt er 45
prozent demokraten oder 45 prozent
republikaner und wir versuchen jetzt
irgendwie durch eine vorauswahl da eine
richtige umfrage zu erstellt das setzt
aber voraus dass alle diejenigen die
sich als demokraten bekannt haben dann
auch tatsächlich für beiden stimmen
das ist aber keineswegs gesichert es
gibt eine reihe von wechselwählern die
zb ihren stimmzettel sehr früh abgeben
das sind häufig einzelne uhr mussten die
etwas ganz anderes an geben als wenn sie
dann gefragt war die man als sie
tatsächlich dann abgestimmt haben
das heißt man schwankt hin und her es
gibt auch viele die zum beispiel auf
ihren stoßstangen trampe abzeichen haben
man fragt man kann nicht sagen ein
erklärter demokrat würde für joe biden
stimmung wir haben eine derart
umfassende koalition zusammengeschmiedet
viele demokraten stimmen für trapp
der zweite grund weshalb umfragen nicht
verlässlich sind
weil das eben häufig fremdgesteuert ist
ganz häufig wird das durch gestochen man
versucht mit dieser sogenannten
wissenschaft umzugehen das ist halte ich
aber eher für ein passendes spieler
kunst stück also wir haben als kürzlich
eine umfrage bei reportern durchgeführt
in washington in der hauptstadt
dort werden sogar gelder gezahlt es wird
geld gezahlt
manchmal auch größere summen eben für
bestimmte kandidaten einzutreten
kandidaten die sich selbst glauben und
das hat ihn häufig auch gesagt wenn man
sich dann den namen der unterstützer
anschaut dann hört man häufig ebenso ist
das heißt es ist äußerst heikel fast
unmöglich hier eine vorhersage zu
treffen
journalisten reporter geben manchmal
auch geld anzubieten damit sie
irgendwelche vorteile bekommen das heißt
es ist ein ganzes system von
journalisten die eben irgendwie irre
geschäftigen auch mit interesse für
unsere zuschauer hier die möglichkeit
doch deutschen zuschauer
dort mit an bord zu sein das ist ja eine
in vielen filmen was man aus spielt doch
mal ein bisschen einblick da rein wie
man dort auf dem flugzeug ist also wenn
es gar bin dann arbeite ich sehr konkret
es ist ein spaß
naja man spürt aber schon die größe des
moments ist dann immer der erste sagte
lass uns doch mal eine aufnahme machen
er wird einem jeder sei zu jeder zeit
beiseite stehen
es ist eine tolle zusammenarbeit
beispiel maria helikopter nummer eins
geflogen bin ins weiße haus
wir werden nichts hier toller augenblick
also erlebt dann ganz in dem moment er
nimmt das auch deutlich war er schaut
sich das an
er hat ja die politik zunächst von außen
beobachtet dass liegen auch die
amerikaner an ihm er ist keiner dieser
08 15 politiker nein er ist wirklich
einer der versucht hat etwas zu ändern
in washington als einer der von außen
kommen und nicht als ein insider
deswegen haben die demokraten auch dabei
sie sind eben zurückgefallen auf das was
sie schon kannten jemand der sich seit
47 jahren in diesem zirkel bewegt er ist
sozusagen eine sichere bank nun weiß was
man an ihm hat aber das gefällt den
amerikaner mussten her
das gab die platzfrage aus berlin viele
deutsche werden wach bleiben kann spät
nachts um zu sehen wer auf sieg wer die
wahl gewinnt wie lange werden wir warten
müssen was man so wann kommt die
ergebnisse reinwand erwartet man die
ergebnisse wie die wahl aus
am abend schnell weiterzugeben jeder der
es wissen will wie sich die stadt nicht
drin bei richards sie können mir folgen
auf den sozialen netzwerken also
wirklich diese ergebnisse so schnell wie
möglich bekommen wir werden was wirklich
wahlbezirke wahlbezirk anschauen es gibt
einige schlüsselstaaten und schlüssel
bezirke wo wir eben besonders schnell
die ergebnisse erwarten zb die muss man
sich einstellen
wir können da nicht sagen welche
kennziffer eben erreicht wird muss von
den demokraten oder republikaner aber so
wir sagen das ist eine art lackmustest
rief die wahl wohl ausgehen wird wird
das dann möglich sein einen verlust an
das wohl wettzumachen
ich denke wir werden das sehr genau
hinschauen je nachdem wird diese
schlüssel bezirke abschneiden
nun ich wage nicht dann so viel schon
eine vorhersage machen
man wird sicher seine handlungen ob es
einen klaren sieger gibt oder ob es eher
ein kopf an kopf rennen
wir werden die klar der abstand ist wir
warten das damit vergleichen wie zum
beispiel briefe noch eingehen die
briefwahl stimmen die ja zum beispiel
nicht ausgezahlt wird jeder staat hat da
andere manche staaten verlangen bis zum
wahltag muss aber der umschlag auch
eingereicht werden andere lassen noch
einige tage zu üben
du hast ihn eingeworfen am wahltag es
dauert aber noch einige tage
wir werden diese stellen mit will 10.000
stimmen sind vielleicht noch nicht
gezählt das waren mit einbeziehen in
unsere abschlüsse
das heißt wir werden uns das genau
anschauen die unterschiedlichen bezirken
und dann werden wir auch eine relativ
frühe einschätzung für den gesamten
staat gegen kriens nun ständig in
bewegung
wir werden also wirklich abwarten müssen
ich bin letzten ausgezählten stimmen wir
werden also warten müssen
danke sprichst du nochmal mit dem ja
nicht an weißen haus aber wir ich werde
so lange wie möglich dort verbringen und
hoffe dann das ergebnis nochmals
herzlichen dank sicher du wirst in den
nächsten tagen weiter noch mal zu uns
kommissionen zum programm danke dass du
warst und das war die richtigen fragen
spezial zur us wahl mit dem ehemaligen
us-botschafter hier in berlin mit
grenade heute abend noch eine weitere
spannende runde von die richtigen fragen
zum thema corona unter anderem mit julia
klöckner mit manuela schwesig und mit
christian lindner hier um 21 uhr 45 bei
bild und ganz wichtig am dienstagabend
schauen sie bei uns die usb auf bild.de
werden sie die ganze nacht informiert
ungefähr sieben uhr abends werden wir
für sie berichten aus unserem wahlstudio
in die usa schalten zu experten halten
eine tolle gäste hier im studio begrüßen
und wir würden uns besonders freuen wenn
wir sie begrüßen können vielen dank fürs
zuschauen hier und einen schönen
sonntagabend die noch
[Musik]